HE SAID IT REPEATEDLY GOING
BACK TO MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
NEW IMAGES FROM THE SOUTHERN
BORDER OVER THE WEEKEND AFTER
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY SEIZED 16 FIREARMS AND
MORE THAN 3500 ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION.
ALSO 181 POUNDS OF METH FROM A
SINGLE CAR.
OFFICIALS SAY THAT VEHICLE WAS
HEADING SOUTH TOWARD THE BORDER
INTO MEXICO.
LIEUTENANT.
WHAT’S THE STATUS THIS WEEK?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
THE PHOTOS, AS MENTIONED,
TROOPERS WERE BUSY OVER THE
WEEKEND.
WE SEIZED THE WEAPONS AND
METHAMPHETAMINE.
IT’S A SIGNIFICANT SIERZ.
THAT’S JUST ONE OF THE LARGEST
WEAPONS SEIZURES WE MADE.
WE HAD ONE BACK IN APRIL WHERE
THE TROOPERS SEIZED 20 AR-15
RIFLES AND OVER 6,000 ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION.
SO SIGNIFICANT SEIZURES MADE
OVER THE WEEKEND FROM OUR DPS
TROOPERS.
>> Bill: IT IS ALMOST JUNE,
LIEUTENANT.
WHAT ARE YOU AND YOUR MEN AND
WOMEN NOTICING NOW?
IS IT BECOMING MORE OR LESS OR
A STEADY PITCH COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER?
>> BILL, ONE THING WE’RE SEEING
IT IS INCREASING.
WE KNOW RIGHT NOW.
>> Bill: INCREASING.
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
SO WHAT WE KNOW I’M TELLING YOU
FROM WHAT WE SEE ON THE FRONT
LINES.
MEN AND WOMEN ON THE FRONT
LINES, WORKING THE BORDER AND
ONES OUT THERE WORKING THE
ELEMENTS DAY IN AND DAY OUT
THIS IS NOT DECREASING BY ANY
MEANS.
WITH THE CONSTANT SURGE OF
MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS, THE
CARTELS, CRIMINALS ON THE U.S.
SIDE ARE EXPLOITING THAT
CURRENT SITUATION AND THEY WILL
PROFIT OFF IT.
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW.
IT IS NOT DECREASING BY ANY
MEANS.
>> Bill: YOUR GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT ON THE DRUGS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY PATROLS THE
BORDER EVERY DAY.
THEY’VE SEEN AN 800% INCREASE
IN THE AMOUNT OF FENTANYL
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY SEIZED THIS YEAR ENOUGH
FENTANYL TO KILL EVERY MAN,
WOMAN AND CHILD IN THE ENTIRE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
WHAT THE BORDER CRISIS IS DOING
THAT BIDEN HAS OPENED UP, IT IS
ENRICHING THAT CARTELS WHO
PROFIT OFF OF MOVING FENTANYL
AND OTHER DRUGS INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Bill: AMERICANS ON THE
STREETS OF MAJOR AMERICAN
CITIES AND SMALL TOWNS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHO PAY THE PRICE
FOR THOSE DRUGS, LIEUTENANT.
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
THE GOVERNOR IS RIGHT ON POINT.
800% INCREASE IN FENTANYL.
THAT’S BECAUSE OF THIS SURGE
THAT’S TAKING PLACE T. CRISIS
NOW.
CRIMINALS AND CARTELS ARE
EXPLOITING THAT SITUATION AND
PROFIT OFF THAT.
BY ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN YOU
EMPOWER THEM EVEN MORE.
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS DEPLOYED
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL TO THE
BORDER TO HELP THE CURRENT